welcome everyone to the second talk
today uh this is going to be by hi how
do
um I have after finishing his PhD at MIT
spent 10 years with us at Google
research uh working both of the ads
optimization team and uh the large-scale
optimization team doing some really
exciting work on solving like huge
distributed LP solvers and after that he
went to the Chicago boot School of
Business where he's a faculty member and
today is going to talk about direct
follow-up work uh to what nikhil spoke
now the differences and extensions and
some other exciting connections yeah
yeah thanks for the introduction and
invitation so I'm gonna follow uh
nikhail's talk so here I just want to
mention like uh I mean I talk about like
online allocation problem but I see like
sort of like equivalent to like the
stack of optimization or like they are
also a few other names like online
programming Etc these are sort of like
similar things okay so I've got a couple
like to talk about some like some of the
new results like in particular
efficiency notationarity and the
robustness
these are also kind of like the answer
to some of the questions in the end
hopefully uh okay so the talk is
essentially based on the first paper
here I'll also quickly mention the next
two papers
okay in this online allocation problem
with resource constraint so these are
like problems that are appear a lot in
CS and or in these problems we have a
fixed amount of resource
and the requests can arrive repeatedly
over time for each request we need to
make a real-time action this action is
going to generate a revenue and consume
some resource our goal here is trying to
design an algorithm that can maximize
the total revenue subject to the
resource code stream
the challenge for this problem is that
like it's an online problem women make
the decision right now we do not know
about the information for future
okay so we kind of like need to decide
something like a dehydrated algorithms
so more specifically here is our model
so we assume we have M types of
resources if resource has a capacity BG
okay and inside we also we're gonna have
like a final Horizon online uh process
with capital T time periods
at each time you're going to receive a
request this request content like three
pieces of information a reward function
ft a consumption function BT and uh
action space Capital XT
so what the decision maker need to
choose action small XT from this action
space
and then this action can generate a
reward fdxt and also consume resource
btxt
so here what we are going to do is we
are targeting as like an online
algorithm so by online algorithm what I
mean is like when you make the decision
you only make the decision based on the
observed history
so here we also uh assume we do know the
total capacity B so B is a capital B is
a vector you have like a multiple
resource and you also know the Horizon
of the problem this capital T so in
practice
um
this T Capital team I mean you always
know B you know your budget but you
sometimes you do not know the capital T
how many requests you can receive and
like I'm gonna talk about it uh how to
relax uh this uh knowing this value T in
the end and for now I can assume you do
know the Horizon t
and also another thing is that like we
need to make sure that the resource
constraints are always satisfied I mean
these are hard to drink you can I mean
these are you can also like violate your
constraint
suppose you know all the information
then you can uh come you can formulate
this like offline problem
okay so your decision is XT you are
trying to maximize the total reward
subject to your body constraint
okay
and
so here one thing I also want to mention
is that like this offline problem have
like more information because it tells
you the future information so the
offline optimal always provides like an
upper Bound for the uh any uh reward
like the rework like any online
algorithm can achieve so in other words
this is like opt just like provide the
upper bound um any online algorithm
so feel free to interrupt me whenever
you want just uh want to make sure uh I
mean it's also like uh
yeah I want it to be like a tutorial
type of talk so let me know if I lost
you
um
yeah that's a great question so here I
post ft and the key are like uh it's
gonna be like some come from like a
random process and here we assuming you
know like the expected rewarded
consumption and there done here
what happened is like
when capital t is large
so whether it satisfies the expectation
of uh hard constraint doesn't matter too
much so I mean you can sing either way
great
um there are lots of applications for
this online allocation problem uh from
black Network Revenue Management in like
Hotel Airline pricing like online linear
programming online matching proportional
matching assessment problem electronic
allocation pricing Etc so what really
motivated me to work on this problem is
this like building in repeated auction
this body is constraint
so here I just want to uh for those of
you like who are not familiar with this
problem just want to give you like a
short background about this problem
uh here I use like a display as as a
example this also happens in like in
search ads or other online advertising
environment
so in another advertising like a big
portion is going to be like a real-time
beating so by real time beating what
that means is that like when a user open
a web page for example like CNN.com so
maybe like a multiple ads showing up so
how these ads are selected they are
selected by our auction okay so they're
going to be like a sort of party called
exchange which holds this auction
and an exchange you're gonna invited
buyers to bid for this impression
and the the like the business like Nike
Etc it wouldn't be by themselves it's
going to hire another third party or the
demand side platform to help them build
and
there are like different like auction
mechanism so a popular one maybe second
price auction so nowadays maybe more
platform utilized first of all first
price auction but like the original
mechanism and usually the high speed
you're gonna Burnside slot and then the
high speed are going to uh window is a
lot of paying their price
so the problem I'm facing is more from
the demand side platform like how much
to bid for each impression okay so more
formally here is a problem
so we have like the total budgets you
can think like the total budget for our
Advertiser for a week or for Amounts is
capital B so you're going to be capital
T incoming impression and here we can as
we can as we assume that key is known
but you can think like you use
historical data to learn this t for now
and then
um in each time period we're going to
receive an impression you're gonna learn
the value of this impression this is a
VP you need to beat you need to beat
your price that is XT that is your
decision
so after beating it if you win you're
gonna pay the uh like uh this DT in
second price auction this DT gonna be
the high speed from your competitor so
your paying value is like this DT uh the
offline problem is this one here so you
are trying to maximize the Surplus which
is your bidding price DTX is a value of
the impression that's the paying price
indicator function like measures whether
you win the ad slot or not here for this
problem our ft is this is objective here
and the BT is the consumption
see how much you spend so we don't we
want to feel like a beat in the
repeating auction to maximize the total
reward subjects to the body constraint
it's the same problem like I introduced
just now
okay
so here why this problem is hard
one reason this problem is hard is
because you really need to you really
need the algorithm to be efficient it
needs to be finished within 100
milliseconds so therefore like you
cannot solve like a large ARP you cannot
use like a dynamic programming to solve
this problem
so furthermore in practice the sample
are like not like I had they are always
like seasonality or not seasonality uh
of the pro in the problem
furthermore
so this VP and DT you may not know the
exact values they come from like a
machine learning model and from a
machine learning model means like you
you may have like noise or errors in
this estimation
um even worse sometimes it happens a lot
in practice that it's like you're you're
the rosary gonna try to corrupt your
data they may try to let you spend your
money or too early so that they can earn
more value in the future because yeah
maybe like crappy the data in the uh
means uh in this like in in the like the
process
so this is how like what we are really
trying to deal with this is like online
bidding problem
okay so now I would like to highlight
what are the difference between like
this work I'm going to talk about and
also the previous talk nuclear game so
there are a few major difference the
first one is like the best of many words
so we're gonna provide like a single
algorithm that can work not only for the
stochastic ID case but also achieve like
Optimal Performance in other input
settings including like adversarial like
a field like a non-stationary setting
another thing is that like with the
efficiency
so in the next we just talk like 60 kind
of like need to solve LP once trying to
estimate the OBT
and in particular in practice if you do
not have a good estimation of the opt
maybe the regret is going to be
proportional to the estimation error
like in like a multiplicity sense and
here in our algorithm we do not need to
solve the ARP what even once and we do
not need to know for example the B2 body
the ratio in our algorithm so these are
this that doesn't show up in the
algorithm
and furthermore I also the last thing is
like I want to talk about is like this
connection to Pi controller
um in practice this uh bidding auction
in like a probably popular algorithm is
like a pi controller so I cannot like
try to build the connection between pi
controller and the mirror descent then
we are able to analyze the performance
of the pi controller as well okay these
are a few major difference compared to
the previous talk
okay so any questions so far by the way
foreign
algorithm that is efficient that can
handle like multiple non-stictionary
setting this can it should be like
robust to the noise of the estimation
it's also need to be simple because
otherwise engineer gonna complain a lot
and finally we want it to have like
theoretical guarantee
okay so the next thing I'm going to dive
into is the input models that means like
how this requests are drawn
like how we get this like request FTP
txt
so one model is the stochastic ID model
that is like what is uh nickel talks in
the last talk and here this request
comes from the same distribution but
it's not unknown to us we're going to
learn this distribution over time
so another extreme is the adversial case
which means you can the the request can
be arbitrarily bad it's given by a
diversary
and these are actually too extreme like
one is ID one is like arbitrary in
practice what all what happened is like
it's neither is the statistic ID no
adversarial it's something in between
okay it's maybe like a diversary
corruption with IID uh and I can also
talk about like two other models like a
market process and a periodic model
these are like three uh constitutional
model like in between of these two
settings
okay so here are like a huge body of
literature I have three slides for the
literature but it's only covered
actually a small portion of the existing
literature here there are a few things I
want to highlight
so the first like
um
for the stochastic ID case
um so so like one minus Epsilon
approximation probably really started by
the paper by uh even though and here's
like in 2009
and then there are a lot of work along
this line also there are many work I've
done like a bad people are here like a
Baloo Shipra detail and uh clumber they
are like like a wonderful work on this
type of problems
so in particular this is the work like
uh like to talk about just now and like
as you can see later on there are lots
of like similarities between uh the
algorithm of our algorithm and the
algorithm but like the difference is
essentially like we are more flexible
and it's like kind of like an extension
of the previous work
it's a diversal case
um there are also quite a lot of work
um but many of them are on like specific
problems like Network Revenue management
and other words what I want to highlight
here is that like
for this like an adverse problem indeed
there is a previous work showing that
like no algorithm can achieve uh both to
Vanishing regulator for the subject of
the ID case and constant competitive
ratio for uh adversial case
so
these are going to talk about like our
results so it's going to get like the
our results our algorithm going to get a
Vanishing regret and also competitive
ratio for the advisor case
is uh these results because like our
competitive ratio are going to be data
dependent I just want to mention this up
front
so for the now stationary setting so
there are not that too many works but
there are a few uh Works talking about
like a different type of like no
stationarity maybe like a cultural
process so suppose you have like some
forecast you may you can do something
clever or they are like a western like
based master generality
okay so any questions so far
the next thing I'm gonna do is like to
dive into the algorithm
so here is our offline problem
when I'm maximize the total revenue
service to the budget constraint
it's a constraint optimization problem
so in constraint optimization a very
powerful tool is a local government do
LED
so here what we did is like we
introduced the lagrangement Dual
variable meal to this to uh to relax the
constraint here is a deal function
okay so okay observation here is that
for the due objective function the
decision going to be decomposed across
time
what I mean by that is like in the
original problem the decision you need
to make the decision I mean the
decisions are correlated because of the
constraint
okay but here if you look at the two
problem now you are able to exchange the
order between the Max and the summation
now if you look at this maximization
problem the maximize the decision
variable is only x t it's not like all
of the XC it's only one single XT it's
like a decomposed over time okay another
thing is this here this part here
the inside is a maximization problem
this is what we call like with address
to rewards so ft is your reward mute mu
is the deal variable you can think that
is like the opportunity cost
and the BT is your consumption if you
use a resource right now you can lose
the opportunity to use them in the
future
so that's why you kind of like want to
maximize the with address reward rather
than the reward itself
so this understanding gives you a
natural algorithm
okay so suppose you do know the optimal
deal variable you know the opportunity
cost
then what you can do is just to make
your decision by solving this with
adjust
um like with a test reward maximization
problem
okay this is this is similar to Nick
Hill's um previous talk is like as it
was problem this meal is like kind of
like Alpha
and in Sun another thing is like how you
are able to calculate uh this meal
so a key observation here is that
so here is a tube function
As Time t
and indeed this Primal action x t tells
you a way to calculate a subgradient of
the two function the subgroup and GT is
essentially this B over T minus b t x t
this GT is a gap between the target
consumption B over T is the target
consumption
and BT here is a true consumption VTX T
is a true consumption the sub gradient
is essentially the gap between the
target consumption and the two
subconsumption now we are able to
utilize like any online Commerce
optimization algorithm trying to update
the deal variable
okay
so more formally here is our algorithm
um
yeah that's a quick question so
okay it depends out the assumption
in the in the uh if if there is no
assumption on F and B so the best you
can get is royalty because you can only
store I mean the resource even in no no
stock because you're gonna spend all
your resources like at T minus order T
but
assumptions for example uh it's a new
function it's like throwing convex and
they are allowed to solve like the uh
offline problem like multiple times then
you are able to achieve like a Long Key
regrets
for example
um
people escape
um okay yeah so here you messaging
yeah you want to make a b to be scared
with t
yeah so that means like yeah you have to
always have like a large parties
yeah yeah
no the constant plan
um
do you know B divided by T what that is
equal to yeah
okay great any other question so here is
our algorithm okay so when we receive a
request we're going to determine the
action by solving this like with
addressed throughout the maximization
problem
and so adjustable population like
sometimes solving this problem will not
be always easy in particular when this F
and B are non-convex
and then we're going to update the build
value we're going to update the
remaining resources and apply the new
variable so here I use a mirror descent
so this part here is the sub gradient B
over T minus b d x t so here is like it
should be a function
and this part here the last part is the
black man Divergence it's just a mirror
descent
so
furthermore
if they choose this age to be vulnerable
two knob Square then we cover the online
gradient descent algorithm just like an
ingredient descent and it projected it
to quality of assets
if you choose H to be a negative entropy
then you're gonna recover the
multiplicative weight update so here is
the algorithm
okay so the intuition here is that like
so B is your total budget T is the time
period p over T is your target
consumption ptxt is your real
consumption so if you if you consume
like more resources than the target then
the two variable gonna get higher and
later are going to be more conservative
in your when consuming the resource
okay
okay so the next thing I'm gonna dive
into is a theoretical guarantee but
before then like any questions so far
okay
so I'm gonna introduce like a few like
notation or assumptions
okay so here we're gonna assume there is
an upper bound
um f upper bound on the consumption as
well and also we can assume there is a
void action well it actually is zero
zero is always in the constraint set
like f zero equal to zero P0 equal to
zero and also B and F are now negative
is upper bounded by this F Bar and B Bar
so furthermore we're going to assume
I mean we don't need to assume like this
with address reward function you can get
computer operable solution but we do
need to assume that you exist optimal
solution
okay so recall like we have a five uh
input model the next thing I'm gonna do
is to go through the theoretical results
for each of these five models we have
the stochastic ID at the bus area the
diversity of corruption uh the market
process and periodic setting okay
okay we'll talk about uh the performance
of the algorithm uh I'll need to talk
about the how to measure the
performance and also the Benchmark so
but I believe that here in this audience
like uh you are very familiar with this
context
Okay so
one thing is it's like cumulative reward
it's a total reward like the algorithm
can collect it's a sum of fft x t and
here we also need to make sure that this
algorithm the DC this XT is given by the
algorithm and this L this decision won't
exceed the body constraint
as a pledge Market compare this is the
offline optimal
okay this is gamma gamma
like this arrow that means like the the
all of the requests so given all of the
request then we we can construct this
like offline problem and we let this opt
to be the optimal offline
so the regret of the algorithm is
defined as a gap between the opt and the
reward
connected by the algorithm
we can also talk about the kinetic ratio
for some of the input model and here is
how we Define the competitive ratio
so here this app is essentially means
opt is Alpha times the reward we collect
so Alpha are going to be a value larger
than that so furthermore one thing I
want to highlight is that we look at
this like asymptotic complexity ratio
which means we look at the case when
this number of sample goes to Infinity
okay if you have final samples then it
probably won't be able to achieve this
regrets this competitive ratio but like
we look at the case when T is equal to
Infinity
okay so here is a result for the uh
stochastic ID case
um which is a cutback it can be reduced
to an instance like if you'll talk about
just now so we can show that the regret
bound of the algorithm is like oh
there's gravity but the major difference
here is that we do not need to know opt
beforehand and in other words we do not
need to solve any large optimization
problem evil events
so this Bond also uh matches the Minimax
regret Bound for this type of problem
any question about this so far
you've got some kind of like it's
a good question
um uh for the stochastic ID uh I'm also
sure about adversarial yes you can so
for syntheticity ID because like I mean
the vanishing regret is like already
very good so I mean there's not too much
need to utilize the structure of like
the casablish under the reward but for
others areas there are of course yeah
there are definitely something you can
do better three but you mentioned you
can get like log T regret in some cases
uh the longitude regret is not this
algorithm it's like a different
algorithm where you need to solve the
offline problem like multiple times
since there is a I mean also like under
more assumption there is a recent paper
by uni and his students which talks
about this
can this algorithm get
up you know unfortunately this algorithm
itself and because of like you you use
up your all of your like results like
results
okay so what that means like okay so you
have this online algorithm right so for
this for this algorithm even though you
know that will start so the best you can
do is like you you better your resource
is going to be used up at this time a p
minus order
that means that you cannot collect the
reward from the last square of t uh
sample and that means like the best
regret you can get is like other the
best you can get is always working so
for the if you know if you have you are
able to resolve the problem like
multiple times I mean so what you can do
is like you can better balance the
remaining budget
and zero you are able to achieve like
yeah you can get to like a long long key
regrets because I have to be kind of
like a better balance about it
allow the past foreign
so what are the extra structure
assumptions that follow you to get or
someone to get lucky ticket yeah so one
structure is like do do function I mean
it's not our work right as well I think
like one a clear example is like a dual
function need to be strongly complex and
that means like
uh maybe okay so that means like this
yeah this ft this request they cannot
like come from like it must come from
like a continuous distribution first
yeah and then you have to do objective
create the durability
so you want to make sure that this this
function here is strongly convex
uh which can be satisfied under like us
under certain assumptions right right
but you do need this this term to be
thrown in convex essentially this term
here to be thrown in convex
this function P Square is linear so yeah
for our case it's piecewise linear
because if you have like fun okay
[Music]
um
okay so here essentially you need to fix
expectation
yeah if you take the expectation if and
B they are not they're gonna come from
like this continuous distribution this
can be yeah
yeah and here is
I'm
saving this might have some
relationships
guarantees for back pressure
maybe there's some connection so maybe
we can discuss that more offline yeah so
do you have a sense why
needed to compute off and now you don't
like you think that even in their
setting you they don't need to compute
the objects yeah because that is
something like we discussed quite a bit
like yesterday today yeah so I mean so
yeah like um just
um the idea is like you need to balance
the uh the Primal that the reward under
the consumption you need opt paid to try
to make a ratio between these two values
so that we have the same units and for
seven like what happens like the Dual
variable can be guaranteed to stay in
about to like standard syntax like the
unit is one the two variables always
units is always one so for us that we
are able to avoid that because
okay so now we we allow to do variable
to go in the whole Space
it doesn't need to be staying in a unit
for
and inside because of the two variable
Can Go the whole space like I mean how
much more freedom that's roughly like
why we do not need to know opt
ions
the algorithm is very similar it's just
it's almost the same the only difference
is like the better your constrain your
due variable you tastes like it's kind
of Simplex or or like you
yeah but if you needed multiplicated
guarantees
okay
kind of like a multiplication results
yeah I'm not sure it seems like that is
something that I'm also sure probably I
think that in that case everyone gets
that maybe you need like you need to
know about
foreign
uh and like for us like
here so it's amazing Injustice it's like
maybe it's not like a slightly better
slightly more performance yeah yeah
I mean these bad pressure algorithms
don't compute off the user Diagon and
there are proofs for
I think
yeah yeah
okay great
um
so here I also want to mention that like
in some cases in some cases like you are
not able to solve this with address
reward maximization problem exactly for
example when you this F and B they are
come from a computer learning model I
mean these are just like estimation or I
can when they are non-convex and then
you may be able to solve it like exactly
there may be some error here for some of
this is a problem and
the good part is like this error gonna
be edited it's just the best you can
hope like in the regress bonus entity
that means like if you if you have like
a maybe a good solution like maybe like
one minus approximation for stopping
this problem then you get like one minus
one over e competitive ratio for the
whole problem as well it makes the
robust to the errors
okay so that's a stochastic case I mean
this the argument goes for all of the
input model
and for the adversial case here is our
major results so we can show like Optics
like Alpha times the uh reward which the
algorithm can get and this Alpha value
is this one here
it looks complicated but essentially
this Alpha value is the ratio between
the consumption bgx is a consumption and
the BJ overt here is a like a Target
consumption or your budget
okay it's a consumption body's ratio can
appear in the uh like a competitive
ratio
okay
so this is a result of the vertical case
and we can also show like this is the
best you can achieve for the general
model
here
um back to like Billy's question like
if we do know there are some structure
of this F and B then there there are
chances that like you can get like a
better than this other star competitive
ratio in particular in AdWords problem
the other problem this F and B they are
proportional to each other and here you
can get like a y minus one over e
competitive ratio which is better than
this Alpha this Alpha is more like a
data dependent compatibration
okay so any question for this
okay
yeah so as a byproduct we can also show
that like even for the universal case
the stopping time of this algorithm is
like T minus all the square of T so you
never deplete your resource too early
okay so this is like you even for the
worst case you your this algorithm can
explain the resource like over time
the next I think I'm going to talk about
is other corruption uh that means like
most of the samples that come from the
IID model but there are Delta instances
that are corrupted by the adversary
in that case what we can show is that
the regret bound is square of t plus all
the delta Okay so in particular when
Delta equal to zero is the is the ID
case x squared T if Delta is like order
T then it's like it's going to recover
the virtual case
and here you can only get like uh other
T regret
as long as like Delta is like you crop
like less subscribe things you are
totally fine
another case is this markup process case
so here uh what happens is like if you
think about like online pricing or like
uh as a location so the stock market
maybe follows like a market process
so here what we show is that the regret
for a market process it can uh gonna be
like oh there's gravity log t so you're
going to lose like a log T term
but like it's just like it's almost tied
up to a locker because like statistical
ID is also a special case of the market
process
and here one thing I want to highlight
is that like
so in this bound like here is another
term show up uh but I put it in the Big
O the term is the mixing type so the
mixing time of the market process is
going to show up in the big old term
okay
and the last input model is the periodic
model so that means like uh so for every
Q uh sample you can come from the same
distribution so this is a periodic uh
input like the period is q
there what we can show is the regret of
the algorithm is order square root of QT
if Q is 1 it's going to recover
stochastic ID case it's like supervative
graphs if Q is T then it's going to
recover the virtual case it's like other
tea regrets
and another thing I want to highlight is
that like
so we use the same algorithm for all of
the five different uh input model I mean
it just means like the same algorithm
kind of achieve like almost the best
performance for different uh like input
models that's why we call it like a
better for many words
so for periodic inputs
it is this time varying in a known way
so you don't you don't do theory on that
but I guess you could yeah so you guys
like okay this is a distribution maybe
it's shifting over time but you know the
distribution how all the distributions
so that actually I mean there is a work
by Javi from Mia able to handle that
case I mean it is it's very easy to
change this algorithm just like it's so
much now the target consumption is Borg
it's uniform so if you know the
distribution you can come up with like a
better spending strategy and for that
you have to start the lp beforehand yes
here you need to solve the lp wise and
then you are able to use that Target
consumption in the algorithm you can
still get a scripture regrets
foreign
[Music]
yeah so within the skills
but like every example then repeat this
is consumption
um
consumption rate there is a guarantee
that you can consume
actually
yeah yeah
so I'm also for maybe let's take a look
so I think like
um
I mean
like how my proof work yeah I think yeah
it's very easy for you to understand for
sure yeah right yeah
so on the rate
so
so
you seem to go in the opposite direction
is going to be more than this value the
smaller than it is
so uh in the adversary case is it easy
to see that the regret needs to be
linear yeah it's easy to say that
I mean essentially
yeah it's more like so suppose like
initially the uh rewarded things clear
and you do not know whether after a
final time you don't know whether to be
working out here then the question is
like whether you're gonna collect
um the action app drops to make a lot of
little kids like because
animals like right yeah so either you
expose the budget thoroughly yeah and
then you're sorry later on but you
didn't exhaust the battery for 10 years
um regarding this office term is it as
possible that you can get yeah
um how this case is the best impact like
for this General problem you could not
have any uh structure of F and B that's
the best you can get right so it's like
you can have a work on yeah
yeah okay there's a worst case instance
like yeah it's a one-dimension instance
like yeah
okay great
Okay so
yeah here again uh the next thing I'm
going to talk about is like a few two
extensions of this line of work one is a
pi controller another one is regularizer
so here I also want to mention that go
back to like the case like if you do not
know this capital T what they do when
you practice this T maybe a random
variable you do not know what exact
people have but you do know that
historical data you can maybe get a lot
of expectation of this t
expectation
and then whatever happens is that like
they're able to be an actual term
showing up in the red part here is the
actual terms like
times standard deviation of t
okay the standard deviation is like not
too large so you still get the
regulatory works okay this is how your
deal is like I don't know
okay so any other questions so far and
it's not going to dive into like a pi
controller
is this in one of your papers
also yeah it's in the yeah I have a
paper for that at the beginning yeah uh
I mean
so here we have a paper so this is yeah
but like I mean
uh we have a version already but like
we're gonna update it like maybe in the
next week
yeah
it's already I have
so many things
but you can read it anyway the main
thing yeah the basically yeah
so yeah
um
is actually very well used in practice
it's a very simple it's efficient and
robust to like non-similarity Etc
but there's actually no theoretical
guarantee for RPI controller for this is
like at least like a participating
problem as far as I know
but on the other hand like this online
algorithm they are very extensively
studied in theory like if you're doing
that like I'm doing that like there are
so many works
however I mean it's less used in
practice
and you see there is a gap between
theory and practice you may practice
people use control theory in theory we
study like online algorithm so the goal
here is trying to bridge this Gap we are
trying to see like whether we can come
we can get like theoretical guarantee
for pi controller and furthermore how we
are able to design like a better API
controller with approval guarantee this
is what we are trying to do
okay so here is the pi controller when
you apply to this dual uh like
allocation problem
okay so the first three steps are the
same You observe the request you
determine the action by using this like
maximizing uh by Solutions like maximum
uh like with address reward maximization
problem you update your resource
and then the difference is that like how
you update the deal variable are going
to be different
okay so previously The View variable is
updated by uh mirror descents or online
algorithm now we're going to update it
by pi controller
so how to do a controller for this like
identity pacing problem
so API controller you're going to
consider this error term
for us the error term going to become
the gap between the true consumption and
the expected consumption this is the
error
so the key observation here is that like
this error term is exactly the same as
the subgradient for the dual function
we said Can Bridge Pi controller to
online optimization literature
and then here is the update for the pi
controller
so I use like this like additive form
like origination form you can also come
up with a multiplicative update version
here is our algorithm the GT is an error
term
okay so keep PGT is the proportional
term KP is a constant
and this is a p in the pi controller so
first of all you have this this term
here this term here is like the sum over
GT sum of the error term this is called
the integral term API controller and Ki
is a constant zero
okay so we're gonna update your Q
variable uh by subtracting both the
proportional term and the integral term
that's the pi controller
okay so is this is the algorithm clear
here
okay
this is what people would use in
practice
uh yes many I always say like in many
many companies people have seen this Pi
until there budget facing is yeah
including like solving for the optimal
action this way
foreign
how close are you start processor
we take the temperature
yeah
that's exactly what he's doing
data is the sum of all the past
gradients but it is
oscillating so this is not just
connected to pay cutter also guidance on
like how Pi controller should be done
for Budget pacing if you directly to the
name one of p and adding all the past
gradients your doom yeah
there is also some difference this is
usually what Pi controller.1 there's a
sequential controller really
plus something usually pay controls are
directly
because
or you're doing a pi controller so to
say on the derivative
and is that difference but buying that
like if you look at this 50 percent
minus DT you should not do k p g d plus
Ki of sum of all the gradients that is a
problem
[Music]
but I fear we are doing like special
ways because like otherwise dramatically
but do you think that we're like
someday some saying
yeah okay so numerically we did observe
that like this algorithm is more robust
to the step size
okay I mean you know because I bet it's
that size I mean due to the best
websites than the algorithm embarrassing
their components but if you have like a
worse sex size this algorithm is a model
password
yeah so you can think yeah this therapy
is
now
so we are kind of providing a more
general form for Avatar API Pi kpl TI or
whatever
we show like I mean it's
is
and like we are trying to come up with a
theory just like that
yeah I mean it's hard for any company to
change their at the um something
subsidious
I mean could there be some rumors
actually a separation and this does
actually like better that when more than
a square root two Factor then
we do not have it yet so what do we have
is just like I mean
before like there isn't any guarantee
for this yeah and now like this worker
is not trying to get a one guarantee
we should again talk more offline
foreign
maybe this will do better yeah yeah I
mean yeah
this is
a momentum actually doesn't spoil it in
fact it does great things
like I mean here it's slightly different
it is more at the moment now
yeah very similar right yes
prediction yeah
future gradients are going to be
momentum is one way of doing that
a few that summer supplies
it doesn't kind of will become at least
the sequential version where I'm doing
Beauty personally good Beauty Plus
something that's what I call the secret
location it's more like the detail I
think
because
we could take it off yeah
I mean yeah there are so many houses you
can play with
it yeah okay
so if you didn't have this uh maximum
zero
already
right distributive true that's why it's
a sequential proportional is the rest of
the world integral because that's not
the world will just repeat the size of
its teams okay so so then the two are
same right just with a different
constant so that integrated
that's the problem is
however
yeah
right in this language P controllers is
enough okay that's one thing yeah so the
integral is basically by putting the
geometric BK you're just adding a finite
window of things like the one by Beta is
roughly all your writings it's still a P
with some history yeah basically some
kind of begin you have to do it's not to
use exponential necessary but if you
don't Decay at all it's a problem
basically you sure
that's not good
whether exponentials necessary or not
it's not clinically that some other PK
is okay
if you don't Decay it's not yeah
right yeah so yeah yeah we have we can
regret it okay so if you click I is
equal to KP then you can write it like I
said
foreign up to that but I think if you
have if they are the same if the aim
equal to KP if this term here can be
written as like the momentum from the
previous iteration
okay great select I mean this is
the same like regret part as well with T
so here one thing I want to mention is
that like if you choose the proper step
size proper parameter and under some
like assumptions we can show that this
is
to grab a t better than the online it's
like constant but they are slightly
better
and by numerically what we need to
realize is like it's more robust to the
step size if you have like a
like a not so good step size this
algorithm is going to perform better
okay
just online learning
right yeah yeah
I mean you know experimentally use like
a random advertising for like yeah I
think like it is
like any moment of sort of like trying
to balance uh
is
so uh okay so I'm gonna escape this part
uh
like this part is like sometimes like
similar to what you feel which is
non-separable rubberizer sure and
maybe like fairness load balancing Etc
and I mean I would say like the
algorithm is also very similar to
declosed algorithm it's maybe like like
one dimension smaller and it's gonna
have like the only difference is like
the target consumption here this is 80
is no longer a constant B over T but the
result is changing over time and also
also depends on the regularizer
yeah
in the theoretical guarantee we can get
gravity with red forces it has the case
very similar to include case we can also
get like a double serial results and we
can get a competitive ratio for this
problem but this company ratio are going
to depends on the regularizer are
okay so that's all I want to talk about
okay so thank you for your attention
[Applause]
so whether you do it at the end to
normalize the pi controller
um
yeah
technique okay so kind of like trying to
map it to like online
but you'll be like as a bad product we
also deal with the first regret about
foreign
is
[Music]
yeah
yes yeah I said try to make it like a
momentum
and based on things
yeah more generals
[Music]
this means it's a newer version yeah
uh Max operations
and this is harder
the new has to be positive so you have
essentially a
projections
okay so that makes the problem harder
okay so okay
um
in this results it doesn't make it
harder and it's a bit harder for this
quality improvements
I mean it doesn't mean you have more
assumptions together like it's got team
to improve but for this for the generic
case is security uh
just get some context I'm like comparing
this talk in the previous talk
previously
so it's more like Okay so
I will say
so this to work like this follow the
same spirit and there are two
elections for like our allocation
problems it's more like probably like
they are like extension of the previous
work and then like
um
I didn't say anything like that like
absolutely
disadvantage of the algorithm except
like okay yeah one thing is that like so
in our analysis
Defenders are the dimension of the
resource
they have like with the Manila
algorithms
of resource that's close uh in the
regret account and in clear algorithms
they have like a dog
that's nothing like a better uh
yeah yeah if you already know like OBT
or something like that we can also get
like extra
yeah
we can have like any estimation of like
OBT gonna give you like uh like a lot of
I mean we can also do that but like just
like in the vanilla version yeah
thank you so I should think of this as
like strictly
yeah
for the separate bookcase like this is
the Terrible Things
it's kind of like I also want to try to
figure out what are the major
universities
yeah I mean there are definitely a lot
of the similarities but like you are
just trying to figure out what other
interests
Pennsylvania
slightly I think they can hear this song
similar particularly yeah
or something
is there a single algorithm now that
could get close
um
I know that can actually it's always
like
required to be solving the problem about
what time over the time that's fine and
all right let's say you don't care about
how of course that much
yeah I mean my answer is
yeah so it's like kind of like there are
so many works
yeah okay all right